If we want to understand
where we've come from,
the stories that have led
us to our present condition,
if we want to
understand our history,
one of the
prerequisites is to have
a good sense of chronometry.
And chronometry,
very fancy word,
but it really is just the
science of the passage of time.
Chrono relating to time.
Metry, time measurement.
And we take many, many things
for granted these days.
We assume that we know
what happened the last 50
years, the last 100 years.
And now we're
starting to assume we
know what happened
10,000 years ago,
or what happened to our planet
100 million years ago or 1
billion years ago.
But these are all very,
very, very new phenomena,
this ability to kind of
shine a light on the past.
And even the traditional
notions of history,
the traditional stories
of, what led to what?
The political nations that
formed, the migrations
of people, and then
when they happened,
that traditional
notion of history
is even fairly
new when you think
about just the scope of
how long we think humans
have now been on this planet.
And that first traditional
notion of history
you can kind of view as the
first chronometric revolution.
And that first
chronometric revolution
that gives us this kind
of traditional notion
of history really just comes out
of humanity's ability to write.
So writing gives us our first
chronometric revolution.
Because this was the
first time, even though we
think humans or
human like creatures
have been around for
hundreds of thousands
of years at this
point, they weren't
able to keep their stories
in a very exact way.
They might have had
an oral tradition.
It might have gone from one
generation to the other.
But with those oral traditions
things would get lost.
And the most important
information that would get lost
is how long ago did
these stories start up?
And we weren't
able, as a species,
to really have a
firm understanding
of when things happened, and
how long ago things happened
until writing became mainstream,
and until writing was done
in a way that it
became permanent.
And our best sense of when
this happened the first time
was by the Sumerians
with cuneiform.
And this happened right around
the third millennia BC, so
around 5,000 years
before the present time.
And this is what some of that
earliest writing looked like.
This is actually a letter from,
I believe this is from a king.
And you can see it's just
highly symbolic carvings.
This is what we more
traditionally associate
with cuneiform.
And it was symbolic-based,
as opposed to now.
Most of our languages
are based on phonetics.
So you have fewer symbols that
can represent more meanings.
But this was a huge
technological revolution.
I could say, for humanity,
because now with the advent
of cuneiform you now had
permanent writing that someone
could look at 1,000 years
later, 2,000 years later.
And if they can
decipher the cuneiform,
they can get a written
testimony of what
was happening at
that time, and they
didn't have to rely
on an oral tradition,
or even guess when that oral
story might have started.
But writing, since it only
happened about 5,000 years
ago-- so this is 5,000
years before the present,
or you could say 3,000
years BC, give or take.
That was a start.
But this only gave us stories
of about 5,000 years old.
And even then it was a very
spotty historical record.
We didn't really get
really deep history,
depending on where
you are in the world,
until really the last
few thousand years.
But it was a start.
This was the first
chronometric revolution.
But what you may or may
not realize is that we are,
frankly, I believe, at
the very early stages
of another chronometric
revolution that has really
just begun to accelerate in
the last 50, 60, 70 years.
And this second
chronometric revolution-- I
should write
revolution up here too.
This was a revolution.
It allowed us to keep
time in a permanent way,
to understand things, to not
have to talk to the people
to whom something happened.
We can see their
written testimony of it.
But the second revolution
really comes out
of the advent of a lot
of our understanding
of modern science.
So in the late 1800s
you have radioactivity
gets discovered by
Marie and Pierre Curie.
So this is 1900 right here.
So this is relatively recent.
Remember, we're talking about
a species that has been around
for several hundreds
of thousands of years,
and protohumans have been
around for millions of years.
And now only 5,000 years ago,
at least as far as we know,
was the first writing.
And then only a little
over 100 years ago
was the discovery
of radioactivity.
And then the ability
to use radioactivity.
So radioactivity is interesting.
It's this idea that,
essentially elements, can change
from one variation to another
of an element over long periods
of time, so through
radioactivity.
So they become kind
of this natural clock.
No one had to go there and
set up a times piece for it.
That luckily, there
are these things
that decay at a very
predictable rate.
So we discover radioactivity
a little over 100 years ago,
and then over the course
of the 20th century
we got better and better,
more sophisticated
at really understanding
radioactivity
to be able to use it to
measure the times of things.
And if you fast forward
to the second half
of the 20th century, so
now say we're at 1950,
this is where the second
chronometric revolution really
took hold.
This is where it
really took hold,
where we started to
understand carbon-14 dating,
we started to understand
some of the other techniques
that we talk about as we start
to date older and older things.
And I want to be clear.
The radioactivity, the
understanding of radioactivity,
was just the beginning of this
second chronometric revolution.
The second chronometric,
which frankly, we are still
a part of, isn't
just radioactivity.
It's also understanding
the expansion
of the universe, the
constancy, kind of the speed
limit of light that
now lets us figure out,
wow, that background
radiation we're getting,
that must have been traveling
for 13.7 billion years ago.
So we can now look at
evidence from our environment.
And our environment is
not just the Earth itself.
It's radiation
bombarding us from space
that gives us clues
as to not just
the age of us, of humanity,
the age of species,
the age of the plant, but the
age of the universe itself.
So it isn't just
about radioactivity.
Radioactivity is a big part of
our chronometric revolution.
This is what allowed
us for the first time,
if we have layers on the
Earth, people have known
for a long time
that if we assume
that these layers
haven't been jostled,
that something at a lower
layer, down here, is probably
going to be older than
at an upper layer.
Because year after
year you have deposits,
if it hasn't been
messed up in some way.
But no one knew.
They said, OK, well,
this is relative dating.
This is older.
This is a younger.
But we had no way of
knowing that, hey,
is this 1,000 years old?
Or is this 1 million years old?
Or is this 1 billion years old?
But now with radioactivity
we could start to say,
hey, we can date some
of the rocks here
that are 150 million years old.
And some of the rocks here are
about 100 million years old.
So maybe this fossil of a
fish that we're finding,
or this primitive fish-like
creature right over here, this
would be between 100 and
150 million years old.
And the only way
we're able to do this
was with being able to date
things using radioactivity.
But radioactivity
is just the start.
As I mentioned, we're getting
better and better understanding
of cosmology.
We're getting
better measurements
of the universe itself.
We're understanding
physics at a deeper level.
Now we can start to
look at the genome,
and think about how the genome
diverges from one species
to another, and how
quickly it changes.
So all of these things
are just allowing
us to get better and better
refinements on the chronology.
Obviously this is a
start, but you still
don't know plus or minus 50
million years how old this is
and how this relates to other
things that we might find.
So I just wanted
to point this out,
that what we take
for granted now,
the age of the universe,
the age of Earth at 4
and 1/2 billion
years old, humans
being around for several
hundreds of thousands of years,
this understanding is a very,
very, very new phenomenon.
It's due to the second
chronometric revolution
that I think we are
still a part of.
And even the first
chronometric revolution,
this version of history--
and I want to be clear.
History was limited by this
first chronometric revolution.
It was limited by
whatever was documented.
But now maybe we can expand
our notion of history.
And a lot of the videos
I've been working on
have been for this big history
project, which says, hey,
before history was limited
by the first chronometric
revolution, to what was written,
by what was testified by people
and was made
permanent in some way,
now chronometry has taken us,
so that we can understand things
into our deep past, before
even the Earth has existed.
So why not redefine
history in a big way
for it to encompass everything,
for it to be big history.
Anyway, I'll leave you there.
And actually I want
to also emphasize
that the second chronometric
revolutions is a big deal.
It allows us to transform even
our understandings of history.
But even this first
chronometric revolution right
over here, 5,000
years is still not
very long in the entire scope
of even human civilization.